[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
oh hello
welcome to frenemies vlog number two we
are down here in beautiful one of a kind
hollywood in the heart of hollywood
california giving an iconic hollywood
bus tour the pink bus because the pink
side is better than the black side
you're on front of me are we in the
heart of home we're in the heart of
hollywood yeah joe's pizza and ph
hollywood hookah
okay yeah today we're hijacking a tour
bus
unsuspecting people we're not hijacking
well it's not like a criminal hijacking
but like the people don't know that
we're giving them a tour that's the the
premise
surprise you're on hidden camera okay
anyway we're gonna be giving our own
version of a hollywood tour to
unsuspecting tourists so with that being
said let's get right into it
all right everybody welcome to uh
hollywood tours
thank you
i am will be your tour guide today my
name is ethan and i've never done this
before
actually to be honest with you guys i
don't even like hollywood that much
it's a little bit of a
let's be honest folks there's not much
to see here
i see people on this tour i don't know
why they're doing it
that's odd
why are you guys here i don't get it how
much you pay for this
20 bucks how much the ticket for this
what's this cost for a tour
40 bucks you guys spent on this [ __ ]
holy sh right
all right well i'll try to give you your
money's worth but
i doubt that you're gonna get anything
substantial out of this store
um
here's a here we go uh
nice little playground here there's a
homeless dude changing his pants hey
all right
hey everybody
just working with the environment here
doing my best
all right well we are headed down to uh
where are we going
beverly hills
to uh
spy on a bunch of celebrities super
creepy
uh you know where all the celebs live
right
do you feel odd about that
no he says no
and uh so we've we've gotten every
celebrity that we can find their address
off like the deep web
google
you looked it up yeah oh i i i heard
private investigators so this is pretty
shady
but we're gonna go scope out some celebs
and uh go go uh
you know violate their privacy that's
what we do here folks
well
there's no way to hide it i mean there's
a lot of homeless people down here
man might as well just call it out right
and i mean god bless them but
hollywood high
oh
wow
there's a high school here yeah
john redder went there oh that's going
to [ __ ] you up going to high school here
all right guys so here we are there's a
car pulled out of it in front of us
we're going to just take it easy ups on
the right say hi to ups
it's empty
we're going to check out charlie chaplin
studios does anybody care about that no
nobody cares about charlie chaplin too
no yeah we do
i'm not the studio
oh
someone's yelling
who's that where did it come from he
said if you're on that bus you stink
like ass no you said that hey turn
around
wait we gotta go confront him
can we do a huey i don't know about that
oh
i don't know i'm kind of down to okay
all right keep it moving keep it moving
i'll tell you what you guys could
definitely be doing something better on
a tuesday afternoon
but that's all right you're stuck with
me for two hours so if you want your
money back uh
it's not happening
all right here's a parking lot on the
right
that's interesting right all right wow
that's a condemned house you get a shot
of that one
holy
holy [ __ ] there's a giant curtain up
there
permit impression what the hell is this
kermit wrong here
that's exciting all right kermit ladies
and gentlemen wow give it up
incredible what a good time huh by the
way it's uh closing and moving to texas
oh what that [ __ ] frog is betraying
us
god you believe that [ __ ] everyone's
moving to texas even kermit
there's a uh
dun edwards paint over here on the right
and a ross right next to it you guys
heard of ross you can find a james
charles palette in there
there's the starbucks where jeff
would've blew me off
that one right there
yo that's the starbucks where jeff when
it blew trisha off you guys this is
unprecedented uh on this store
unbelievable
so if you guys under the story jeff
whittick blew the famous trisha paytas
off there she he she was he saw her in
there
and he
left his order on the counter and left
the starbucks and that's when the famous
beef started you guys this is huge that
we're seeing this
there's a guy recording us hey
hey dude window down what's up
nothing to see here
you got 40 bucks for this store man
he ain't getting it for free
wow i can't believe we saw the starbucks
where jeff wedding blew trisha off folks
is this something or what
wow wow what a star wars tour
unbelievably good times here
wow wendy's on the left there wendy's
excellent
hey debbie lovato billboard what
billboard billboard oh
demi lovato ladies and gentlemen
on the billboard she uh
she heard she rumor has it she's still
upset about the yogurt incident to this
day
her day is still ruined folks we feel so
we the hearts go out to demi lovato we
got hand prints to the guitar we got
handprints
who's handprints
we got handprints whatever that means
guys take a look mickey's sick we got
handprints
wow
cool you guys see the hand prints yeah
wow
all right oh i have some i have some
commentary coming up okay you want a
tour here you want to free here take the
ticket i have a lot of good stuff coming
up for real okay go okay girl
you're introducing me
though introduce yourself okay
well this is weird hello oh hold on
hey guys i'm trish a second host of
frenemies we were originally supposed to
be in costume but ethan bailed on me
look made me look like a loser this
outfit but we're a theme we're thematic
okay so this is like my spot i have
history here and i'm very excited to
take people on a tour this is very
exciting all right hold on let me see
what's coming up oh oh oh oh um
this used to be a kfc and it's not a
zanku chicken wow
that is insider info
no i gotta know i have good stuff i
promise hold on
let's take a minute because this strip
is like my strip you know i used to like
do you want to say something to
starbucks people um
no that used to be a coffee bean and tea
leaf that's why i saw bob sagan in real
life
why is he suing you oh cause i said that
he was creepy on tick
okay
tock
um coming up is the laugh factory and
this is where i used to sell meat for a
guy and we'd sell it on the corner of la
factory
meat meat yeah his name was josh nasser
he was a comedian that also stole meat
and yeah meat meat you sold me meat on
the corner of the lab factory hot dogs
no like frozen meat that you could cook
like steaks were you in a store on the
street on the street because he would
like perform there and i was like his
assistant and we used to sell meat
um let's that's odd there's also a
jewish deli
um kosher okay there is something else
coming up too i used to be i'll show you
okay to the left we have hyde this is
club is the first time i did heroin
it was a fun time i was very skinny
and then over here is the famous chateau
vermont where john belushi actually
overdosed fun fact i puked on the butter
noodles that night when me and moses
went there was blood on the sheets
wow it was a pretty good time
let's go yeah there it is that's how it
looks very scary this is uh oh let's see
here there's more oh oh
this is where to the right was body shop
i auditioned here at 18 years old to be
a stripper and told i was too fat so i
went to the valley
yeah skinny girls only
but it's okay it's pretty iconic still
uh oh my favorite site is coming up
it's coming you guys get prepared to the
left we have coming up the world famous
saddle rant home to the douche bags like
david dobert bryce hall
it really is iconic
so comedy store um yeah i used to work
there as well
nothing good happening there although
andy kaufman did perform there
haunted like they say
comedy store haunted
um
no i don't think so
okay so we are approaching um the famous
part of the sunset strip well it used to
be famous this was like in the heyday
viper room johnny depp i used to come
here in 2006 like wait 25 years past its
prime when i dated um
oh i don't know i guess i shouldn't say
thank you say it
know
but we used to go here and they were
like 50 years old and they were still
like doing drugs and [ __ ] like that and
they were like hooking up this is when i
was like 16 years old and people were
like hooking up with me it's kind of
gross actually it's a little dark but um
it's it's still there
nicholas cage oh my god fun fact though
not that i know this oh i do know this
but i don't know him personally nicholas
cage met his wife at this little sushi
place it's called blowfish sushi but
it's no longer there it was right across
from boa and that's where you met you so
i ended up trying to get a job there but
i didn't get hired because i had no
prior experience so there's the viper
room where joaquin phoenix stein i took
a death tour one time in hollywood and
they just showed us places where people
died
but um he did die rest in peace
um
yeah
[Laughter]
my bad
i knew it was one of those people that's
sad though but iconic okay did we get
roxy stories
i only went to the roxy there was a guy
there's a band called faster pussycat in
the 80s and i did this guy named tammy
down and he used to like
i can't really tell any of these stories
because they're just not like family
friendly but we used to know the roxy
all the time
here's the whiskey a go-go i really only
know this from rock of ages i've
actually never been myself but it looks
like kind of a kind of a bump i did a
lot of drugs down here because i thought
it was cool but
what kind of drugs did you do um
everything coke meth heroin nice
true hollywood experience i thought it
was so cool i was like 30 years too late
to the cool scene of sunset it was like
past its prime oh the rainbow room
another this is another place where it's
poppy popping popular they let me in
underage there the rainbow room is
famous for a lot of people that are 16
and you're supposed to be like over 18.
i don't know now we're going into
beverly hills so wow
yeah that was good that was all i knew
about hollywood
i don't know any of that stuff okay
amazing wow trisha fantastic
that was great because i don't know
anything about any of that stuff i
haven't done meth crack heroin or
anything fun exciting actually i did
smoke crack once that's a lie yeah yeah
i did smoke crack once
it wasn't glamorous it wasn't fun
it was a small hit you guys it was don't
judge me it was a very small hit or
crack
no judgment
yeah thank you i was at my friend's
house i had some a little friends who
were literally on the little shadier
side and they started um
cooking cocaine into crap
i took a hit
not a big deal thank you guys thank you
crack one time
i did crack one time thank you
so we're heading into beverly hills
um we're gonna go harass some celebs all
right that's what the store is all about
there's boa that's the other famous
place to go get paparazzi okay boa
that's where like the demilia's gone
like i don't get paparazzi and then
they're getting like that's where
paparazzi is all the time all righty we
should go out like nine so we can get
paparazzi you know i always say that and
you say you don't want to yeah i
definitely don't let's let's keep her
yeah i love ringo peace and love peace
and love this is a serious message to
everybody watching
this update right now
is he here is here tom said something
about ringo's star we're going to go to
his driveway oh we're going to go to his
driveway
oh that's
so amazing
i got to do my i've been training for
this you guys i've been memorizing his
peace and love speech
oh he's gonna hear me oh god i'm gonna
shout come does the speaker get louder
we've got we've achieved louder volumes
all right we're approaching ringo's
let's try to keep it down we don't want
to scare him
he is a member founding well he wasn't
founding he kind of
he was a member of the beatles let's
just say that second wave yeah yeah but
he's you know he's a beatle we don't
take that away from him ringo stars in
icon
and uh he loves when big giant tour
buses of people come outside his house
and scream for him which is what we're
gonna do here today
so we're in beverly hills
where people come to have peace and
quiet
and we're here to disrupt that oh is
this it
stars on the gate oh okay
okay stop here
this is a serious message to everybody
watching my update
right now
you think you can hear me peace and love
peace and love
ringo starr well he's got the stars on
his gate did you make that up because
there's stars on the gate
wow a little bit of a really star man
kind of tone it down a little bit with
stars everywhere i mean i get it it's a
little gaudy it's a little gutty toned
it down ringo
okay you know what though jeffree star
has stars too at his house so maybe it's
his second house i don't like that
that's old place right now who's that
ellen degeneres
oh
sorry
old clay she doesn't live there anymore
okay
so just uh so we've seen ringo starr and
ellen you guys feeling entertained here
today well we didn't see them but we
didn't see them we saw
their driveway and gate and
you know
brushes
david courtney
wait that's his house right oh they were
why you know if they were there then we
don't really care about that i mean
i want to know where they are right now
jackie chan michael jackson who lives
here
i'm sorry but like i'm here to see the
celebs house not they used to live here
oh hi did jackie used to live here is
that true
we asked the current resident but
we didn't get a yes or no answer
we moved on quickly
that's a shame
wow whose house is this
so once again once again just for
clarity guys
the osborne's was shot here they don't
live here
but they shot here does that interest
you 20 years ago oh they did okay
fascinating
where's the playboy mansion isn't it
around here
yeah
you can't see much but you can see the
rock that you speak into
okay it's iconic
guys
guys sandra bullock lives here she's had
three stalkers break into her house so
we shouldn't advertise it
walk on thin ice with the tour buses
coming over here oh yeah
tom is saying that uh what shot won't
hurt i guess they they yeah tom is
warning that uh
the celebs sometimes complain about it
they'll call the cops
what are they gonna do about it they'll
give us one over the weight limit
yeah well i dare him to come out here
triggered
over the weight limit yeah excuse me fat
shaming
i dare them to call the police
yeah this is my tour bus could you
imagine we get a ticket for being over
the weight limit oh my god that's so
triggering oh i i yeah
if there's a limit weight limit though
we are way over seven
oh [ __ ] the cops are right there
actually should i not say anything yeah
should i say oh [ __ ] okay everybody
everybody at cool there's an officer on
our left
everybody at cool
everybody be cool about this oh my god
all right all right this is a hell of an
adventure are we going to your house i
feel like we're getting close no
you want to do you want to do the
playboy manchester united you want to
take over is it are we close
five minutes five minutes take over
you know what i only took the hollywood
death tour for real because someone was
murdered here in her mercedes was a
publicist you remember that right here
on sunset wow
and bill cosby's son was murdered off
sunset boulevard this exit so i only
know like the deaf ones dr laura's mom
was cocooned into a coma over here and
she was in her apartment for three days
um
yeah some actress was killed by her
stalker there's just a lot oh is this
the beverly hills hotel
that really is hot we were gonna have
our wedding here but trash they didn't
have any opening availabilities i think
they said it to us but i think they
thought we were trashing it
[Applause]
yeah yeah
this intersection i definitely got in a
car accident there's a six-way
intersection right this and this gets
into car accidents all the time
i have a few stories about being at the
playboy mansion i used to go from 18 to
21 and they would always take pictures
of you right and i was always a little
thick um but i got thicker as the years
went on and i remember one day half came
up he always did like a molest he always
kind of like groped your body like this
and i had a little belly because i
stopped doing drugs and he's like oh he
goes i see you've gone a little curvier
and i never got invited back after that
it was really really sad
i know they really did ban me i couldn't
even go to the big parties where they
had like a ton of people they were like
oh hold on hold on i've become one of
the hollywood death tour things and i
was like oh [ __ ] i'm sorry
i'm sorry you could get killed
i knew this one the michael jackson all
this is this where he died or just oh
we're gonna yeah yeah i've been to this
one david spade also lives here he
always takes pictures of people taking
pictures in his driveway and i think
that's some [ __ ] it's like this
right here is a really photogenic spot
and david spade will come out and make
fun of instagram girls taking their
pictures in the middle of the street
wait let's go see if we can get him to
take a photo of us
yeah he's around here somewhere it's
like the palm trees i just recognized
the area like this spot and he's like
right on the street like this too he's
like look at these losers taking
pictures
okay david david's made the loser
he always ignored my dms until one day
his girlfriend wanted to meet me and
he's like hey trish my girlfriend's a
big fan can you say hi and i was just
like you've ignored me for 20 years so
no thank you
you got him i don't like david
um
so this is michael jackson's last
residence according to tom our bus
driver he's to stand on the balcony say
hi
so sad this area feels spooky like it
feels like it's very scary i don't know
about it otherwise there's so many
deaths in beverly hills
like rich people just sat i guess
2009 the day of tragedy stress what does
that mean
what happened in 2009 michael jackson
died
oh sorry
oh my god okay trisha yelled at them i'm
not gonna yell at them
they're right there but they're right
there we don't know who's in there let's
find out
let's not
ugh we ate pizza right before getting on
the bus and i just feel so sick right
now oh we had the greco's pizza by the
slice so we were in the car how many
slices two oh just two yeah are they big
huge oh really and they are they wasn't
well done and we saw dan and his
girlfriend and i hate making eye contact
with people when i eat and i was like oh
they're judging me for being a big bad
pig in this car right now did you judge
them dan that's what i was thinking i
was just like
moses looked over i'm like don't make
eye contact i'm eating and i look like a
pig just ravaging playboy manchester is
it here
fun fact he actually like went bankrupt
five years before he died and this was
sold but the agreements was that he
could live there until he died i talked
to crystal hoffner about this on the
dishwasher's podcast and she said that
this was the truth and that they were
bankrupt and sold it
hey
where
oh beyonce and jay-z does anyone
currently live in these houses like
celebrities no
they all moved out oh yeah there's the
rock what's the what's all this hubbub
about a rock you speak into it to say
like i'm here for whatever i see
nickelback shot their video rockstar
here fun fact
we're here girls next door speaking to
the rock
i think he's dead though
right didn't he actually die
recently right
yeah
that's what i thought but everybody i
assume somebody's here though
i don't think so i think they're making
a museum i don't think anyone lives
there oh really um yeah
oh my god somebody bought it for 200
billion somebody bought it for 200 is
that true 200 million that sounds like a
lot that house was small and now we're
going in
yeah yeah good luck getting impaled i
just wanted to say that um where's pdd's
house
right here on the right
okay so i know something you guys need
to know about p diddy's house is that
zacchaeus foreskin
is buried in the yard
that's four skin give it up for zach's
foreskin
thank you ladies and gentlemen i can't
see you thank you all right wait this
house
you're going to say zach
tam tom is going to work that into his
tour now
zach's foreskin
oh this is it
so p diddy lives here
[Laughter]
i had my childhood in this home
daddy
i want my foreskin back
oh jesus
rest in peace biggie smalls we love them
too
yep let's find some more celebs to her
ass
uh you think we've gotten any police
calls for today that'd be kind of
exciting
that'd be a fun way to end the tour
have you ever have you ever been pulled
over by the police
oh many times for the over the weight oh
many times and then what it's just tours
over you gotta pay
no you just have to pay the ticket just
wet their beak
300 500 oh [ __ ] not your problem though
you pay it what kind of [ __ ] [ __ ]
is that
you driving and they make you pay that
[ __ ]
what
that's a [ __ ] tom
yeah but the bus owner should pay that
no oh
tom guys tom is being forced to pay
overweight tickets
shame on all of you who have not been on
a diet
oh my god
just kidding
it's not about the individual weights
it's about the quantity of people
sure let's see where princess aleya grew
up ladies and gentlemen she died she's
dead as well is there anyone living on
this store
so apparently a lot of people die around
here just a lot this is kind of like a
lot of death old people and and just
horrible things happening here
so who's hungry
me
oh oh trish is hungry i mean i'm a
little sick from the pizza but i could
use something to stabilize what do we
feel like
dominoes chick-fil-a burger king
mcdonald's in and out what if we call
some food to pick up and we just chill
out on the bus and have some food
now that's a [ __ ] tour i could get
behind
right
yes
all right what do we feel like guys
we're on a tour uh i got some dominoes
pizza trisha what do you feel i don't
care
chick-fil-a come on you guys let's get
some enthusiasm for the food ladies
all right we got the big guy back here
is very vocal any of you guys got an
opinion
what do we got bubble tea tea bubble tea
okay all right guys we're going we're
doing the boba team what does that mean
[Laughter]
all right we got boba tea would you like
a boba tea tom
all right top dog
all right yeah we got to get some boba
fish
she's dead
i've been informed she's also dead
sorry i just gave leno like mission
impossible
everyone seemed stoked on boba tea
here let's see
right here ben siegel ladies and
gentlemen died right here
excuse me miss did you know ben siegel
died right here
she didn't know that yeah now you know
can we can we get a um postmates to the
car
and have him chase us
that's a moving target all right i think
the next street for real is david
spade's house those palm trees oh let's
go to damage space maybe pull over by
that road right around the corner i know
because i see him do it every day on
instagram yeah he gets pissed like
standing in the middle of the road okay
so right now we're going to see if we
can bait david spade into coming out
david
i would say middle park in the middle of
like you know david
oh my god david spade we know you're out
here somewhere
i just want to be on his instagram story
let me down david spade damon spain
david we got a bus of big fans out here
are we are we davis oh we don't really
like that
oh we like david yeah
you just said you hate me
i don't like current david spade i like
david's baby back in the day like
tomorrow
out of a speaker yeah let's just take a
stop get some boba tea
okay
there we go
you ever park in these neighborhoods and
just chill yeah this is at first for you
awesome this is our first ladies and
gentlemen parking and chilling in
beverly hills
amazing
all right so we're locating some bubba
tom what do you feel like eating
tom you call it i was just thinking
shake shack back in west hollywood okay
tom is calling out shake shack you guys
so we can take santa monica shake shack
back to west hollywood and get in there
how's that wow
15 burgers and 15 fries
oh does anyone else want a veggie burger
how many veggies we got here one
just one just one oh sorry
sorry tom got excited about shake shack
one veggie burger how exciting everybody
what the hell is this hey so you know
what you're gonna call him ahead what
the hell was that damn
floyd made weather ladies and gentlemen
look with this fight with you got your
head gotcha
floyd mayweather who is going to be
fighting
logan friend of the show logan paul yeah
friends of the show
friend of the show which i will not be
pirating by the way
i will be streaming legally
or not watching let's get really just
not watching can i make a correction
real quick you want to take the mic can
they hear me here take the mic no it's
for frenemies um we should clarify can
you really put this in that it wasn't
jordan fisher the evan hansen i was
talking about it was andrew barth
garfield i think his name was and he
actually looked 16 the guy who played
evan hansen all the comments are really
pissed that i got it wrong yeah you got
that you really [ __ ] that up andrew
barth garfield this is a reference to
the frenemies episode so i just wanted
because there was a ton of comments on
it and people were really oh yeah i mean
you really [ __ ] that up and he didn't
look like he the other guy does look
like he's 16 so my apologies i don't
want people what's his name what's
and this kid's actually 16. and he
played evan hansen on broadway and this
is the one people wanted ben plant
played it on broadway he originated it
but there's been like he grew up
yeah i think that's important good
direction i thank you the comments are
so upset
so we are now headed to this is the
hotel
what time is it it's like 1 30. wake up
oh my god what a four it should be up by
now it's only one or four
wake up
all right it's a wake-up call
it's one o'clock they have the best
hamburgers at the polo lounge we should
have ordered hamburgers from there
they're like 50 a piece
that's so good the pole lounge is cool
oh can you do that yeah floyd's house
right floyd right here is he absolutely
there oh there's somebody in the window
hey hey
floyd
flying up the window
yeah i saw that
floyd win mayweather ladies and
gentlemen
[Music]
[Applause]
how much you spent on that
20 million
he's so rich though he's got like
jewelry that costs 20 million
yo you got beef with the other tour
companies
yeah [ __ ] them
it's dough
tom cruise used to live here
are we successful
300 of shake shack let's go
13 shack burgers two veggie shacks three
15 cheese fries seven shakes
vanilla shakes eight chocolate shakes
let's [ __ ] go
tom got excited it's lunch time
let's go oh what's this why is this
plumber looking like a tour company
guaranteed
plumbing i kind of want to run it to
other tour buses if we can beef with
them that would be fun
i had friends in high school that
fell out of a bus really i mean i'm
holding on
thank you as long as this thing doesn't
swing unexpectedly you had friends
plural you have multiple friends that
fell out of the box i had one friend and
then his best friend at his at their
friend's wedding fell out of the party
bus on the highway
wow
jesus yeah right are they okay
no they're dead i don't want to kill the
buzz but they're dead
i just was telling to be careful
well bro what why would you bring that
up i asked him
wait bring it down
separate deaths bus related deaths
i'm holding on tight listen i got i'm
going to get shake shack i'm not dying
trust me
nothing's going to kill me hold on
well i just let let's get a pull let's
get a pulse for the city let's talk to
some people on the street
let's see whatever this is we're heading
over to an apartment building that's not
your own
apartment building
monroe had rented a unit in this
building marilyn monroe has rented to
get this
an apartment
in this building we're going to be
checking out
and there's a picture online maryland's
standing right in front of the garage
door nice to meet you
hey guys
we got a white key over here hi we got a
white kia on our left the middle finger
hello right with two dudes sitting in it
fascinating stuff on our tour here
two gentlemen sitting in a white kia
all right
we have a uh we've got a girl here
walking her dogs on the left
she's walking her dogs
we got two dudes sitting down on the
curb here
love that
the sights you see out here in hollywood
los angeles
coming up on the right we have a man
walking dogs
there's a man walking three dogs on the
right doggies
shout out to him
[Music]
and coming up here on the left there's a
man getting in his black truck
and his back
fantastic stuff here
and on the left is a woman with an
orange rucksack of some kind with wheels
she's looking across the street
she's waiting across the street take
care oh we're approaching we're
approaching the sheriff
do you want to sit down got it coming up
on the right is a man in a blue shirt
yeah blue shirt on the right walking
he's walking
blue shirt guy take care you vaccinated
yes he is
[Applause]
we love that we love that wait can i
take over for a second yes spam
i have a dream and i want it to start
we're getting to my favorite part of la
and this is west hollywood weho home of
the gay pride parade starting june 1st
this will be closed up and we can march
the streets as the lg btq plus there's
chichi larus there's mickey's that is
finally opening up june 15th block party
we have this is flaming saddles is the
place where i went and saw my first drag
queen this is the best area because you
can walk around with your ass out in gay
pride month and people live for it and i
just wanted to do a little something for
the gays um i have a song from liz
mcguire movie called what dreams are
made of i'm going to perform it for you
right now
[Applause]
on right now
okay have you ever seen such a beautiful
night
i could almost kiss the stars for
shining so bright
when i see you smiling
i would never want to miss this cause in
my heart i know what this is hey now
this is what
jeans are made of
this box is out of control
i got somebody to love this is
i've always wanted to do that
i'm so excited for gay pride
can you help us with people on the
street no we're in a gay area i'm not
going to hug them oh it's like a hate
crime what yeah everybody's gay
all
let's go so right
can i smoke on your bus
let's smoke dude that's insane
just no putt
no pot just a cigarette
this is the greatest store ever
we're smoking on the tour bus wait you
can do that yes
give it up
give it up wow
we got napkins
wow
all right raise your hand if you got a
vanilla i did you got your mail zach
don't worry
guess what it's [ __ ] best foods oh
thank god
[ __ ] friend
you're gonna leave it
you gotta take off you can take off
well we had a good time didn't we folks
[Applause]
hopefully tom here doesn't get any
citations we're rooting for you tomorrow
yes sir here let's say hi to the folks
on the street here guy here in a in a
purple jersey
blue and purple jersey with white shoes
take a look at him
coming up here is a girl in a green
dress
floral design
[Applause]
excellent
coming out here we got some dude in a
blue shirt
he's got a la bag and a blue shirt and a
blue hat
[Applause]
not you sir your friend blue shirt blue
mask yes
there we go now where else where else
can you see a man in red shorts
and a white shirt with a nike switch
yes i am
take care
hey we got to do it in a blue shirt here
the black hat that's right
we got two minutes everybody let's make
it count two minutes
make it count
let's make it count oh okay coming up on
the left here it's really exciting man
in a red shirt and a trunk sitting in
the trunk of his car red shirt gray
pants singing the junkies on his phone
he's got glasses and a mask he's sitting
in his trunk okay
this is only in hollywood coming up on
the left here you got green hair woman
with green hair black shirt she's got
big black boots only in hollywood
guys her mouth kind of flew off there
take a look on the left there
hell no hell no
this is like this is only in only in
hollywood folks we got green hair she's
heckling back this is exciting
coming up on the left here wow this is
exciting we got a purple kind of
headband
grape shirt he's got a cute little white
dog we love that about him
well come to the end of our tour here
but uh we got a man in a blue hoodie
over here on the left pretty exciting
blue hoodie
okay coming up on the left here
coming up on the left we've got a whole
group of young girls here
take a look at this only in los angeles
california can you see a group like this
we've got photos we've got a black shirt
holy [ __ ] what is happening here folks
hi okay we got a girl taking pictures
here
[Applause]
wow what is happening
wow wow wow
holy [ __ ] what is happening
wait why are you guys all what's going
on here we're here girls
girls
[Applause]
only in hollywood all right tom take off
this is our parking spot you're gonna
let us out
[Applause]
tom why have you done this
all right well this is the end of our
tour
where apparently
we're being thrown to the hyenas so
thank you tom
wow
all right
trisha you want to say you want to say
something thank you so much for joining
the frenemies hollywood tour if you want
your tickets go to the h3 podcast email
dan he'll set up a tour
yes